[Música]
vamos a las noticias desde la economía
con danielle hablando en esta noche en
directo américa edición al nocturna
daría la buenas noches para todas las
noches angela bueno después de este
saludo vamos a entrar en materia comenzó
la venta de divisas a los ciudadanos en
el mercado cambiario cubano claro que si
angela y lo primero es cómo describir lo
que ha pasado y es que la creciente
escasez de dólares condujo a una
devaluación del peso y eso hizo que las
divisas llegadas desde el exterior
fueran más valiosas para los cubanos por
eso el gobierno aplicó una nueva
política diseñada también para hacer
frente al mercado ilegal hace casi tres
semanas el gobierno comenzó a comprar
dólares al público a 110 como a 40 pesos
por unidad más de 4 veces el valor
oficial y hoy empezó a venderlo por
primera vez en dos años escuchemos lo
que piensan los cubanos
puedo hablar a
luchar por adquirir lo pueda obtener un
poquito de la bilis
los problemas no tengo familia esta
oportunidad han dado nada bueno el
precio incremental mismo con trabajando
mucha gente no tan bueno
y en otras noticias de ese país soy el
gobierno reconoció que la nación se
enfrenta a serias dificultades para
importar harina de trigo debido entre
otros a las dificultades valga la
redundancia financieras que ha tenido
esta nación una escasez que se suma a la
de otros productos básicos y medicinas y
es que cuba importa cerca del 70% de los
alimentos que consume daniela en otros
temas en la cepal elevó la proyección de
crecimiento para américa latina en 2022
cuéntenos así después en abril en la
comisión económica para américa latina y
el caribe estimaba que la región iba a
tener un crecimiento del 1,8 por ciento
este año ahora piensa que ese
crecimiento será del 27 por ciento y
aunque esta proyección mejoró es casi un
punto porcentual por encima de lo que se
preveía antes si alguna advertencia de
que el escenario sigue siendo bastante
complejo
las con restricciones externas internos
los problemas del desafío de dinamizar
el crecimiento combatir la inflación
mantener políticas sociales y hacernos
cargo de los cuerpos sociales ya la
región sería que no están al más fuerte
la pandemia dinamizar la inversión
requiere un nuevo mix de política fiscal
tanto fiscal monetaria como cambiaria
que den cuenta de este nuevo desafío ec
y poner sobre la mesa
precisamente hoy se conoció angela que
la actividad económica de argentina que
es como una cifra previa a lola del
producto interno bruto acumuló en el
primer semestre del año un crecimiento
del 6,3 por ciento aunque está
aumentando lo hace en un nivel cada vez
más bajo que en meses anteriores y la
casa blanca también ajustó sus
proyecciones económicas pero a la baja
claro está es una revisión
presupuestaria que hacen cada cierto
tiempo y es la más reciente muestra cómo
han evolucionado las proyecciones entre
marzo de este año cuando apenas iniciaba
la guerra y junio se espera entonces un
menor déficit gracias a la ume de los
impuestos corporativos también un
crecimiento del 1 4% del producto
interno bruto para este año menos de la
mitad de lo previsto en marzo una
inflación más del doble de la esperada
en marzo del 6,6 por ciento y un
desempleo casi estable en 3 7%
adicionalmente se espera que job aiden
anuncio mañana la condonación de hasta
10 mil dólares en deuda estudiantil
federal a cualquiera que gane menos de
125 mil dólares al año ahora quisiera
pedirle por favor para nuestros
televidentes los indicadores de la
jornada claro que sigue igual los trades
del cerro este martes en rojo en el
segundo día de una semana con el
simposio de la reserva federal en
jackson hole wyoming como protagonista
en europa del principal índice de la
bolsa de parís cerró en negativo por
tercera vez consecutiva y si nos vamos
para américa latina argentina y brasil-
se saltaron más del 2% también es
noticia bursátil venezuela que cumplió
hoy 100 días de retraso en la salida a
bolsa de varias empresas públicas esto
había sido prometido para el presidente
nicolás maduro sin embargo las
operaciones debieron comenzar el 16 de
mayo y todavía hoy bursátil no ha
recibido la luz verde por parte ni del
gobierno ni de las empresas involucradas
y cierre con cifra el 33,9 por ciento
fue la cifra de desempleo en sudáfrica
en el segundo trimestre de 2022 es el
segundo descenso consecutivo frente a
casi el 36 por ciento del último
trimestre de 2021 en ese momento había
marcado récord histórico
bueno daniela puede ser gracias a usted
y la dejo porque ahora nos vamos con
directo